vous savez notre principe fondamental
c'est de réussir à maintenir les écoles
les collèges et des lycées ouverts pour
avoir une école une année scolaire aussi
normale que possible
c'est chacun le sait une particularité
française que d'avoir réussi cela pour
l'essentiel jusqu'à aujourd'hui c'est
notre objectif est évidemment qu'il en
soit ainsi
jusqu'aux vacances d'été avec des
inconvénients des des imperfections que
je suis le premier à reconnaître mais
néanmoins une situation bien plus
favorable pour les élèves français que
pour pratiquement tous tous les élèves
auxquels ils peuvent être comparés en
europe ou dans le monde et donc cette
cette conviction profonde de
l'importance de l'école nous a amenés
derrière le président république et le
premier ministre à concevoir au mois
d'avril un un confinement qui éviter au
maximum le nombre un nombre trop
important de jours manqués pour pour les
élèves
chacun se souvient des principes que
nous avons retenu c'est à dire des
semaines des vacances de printemps
commune à toute la france donc une sorte
de dézonage et puis le départ
devant confinement en tout cas la non
présence physique à l'école des élèves
du primaire des collèges et des lycées
dans la semaine qui a précédé ces
vacances de printemps avec un
enseignement à distance sur lequel je
reviendrai qui a caractérisé aussi la
rentrée des élèves de l'enseignement
secondaire dans la semaine du 26 avril
tout ceci donc a fait l'objet d'une
préparation importante et qui maintenant
se déroule devant nous cette préparation
importante pendant les vacances de
printemps et c'est accompagné aussi du
fait que comme cela était prévu nous
avons accueilli aussi bien pendant la
semaine d'enseignement à distance que
pendant les deux semaines de vacances
des élèves des enfants qui étaient les
enfants des personnels priorité à c'est
à dire notamment les enfants des
personnels soignants chacun il se
souvient qu'on avait fait cela lors du
premier confinement avec environ trente
mille enfants par jour
je voudrais indiquer que nous avons eu
autour de 175 mille enfants chaque jour
pendant la première semaine puis alors
que les collectivités locales prenaient
un peu le relais dans ce qui correspond
semaines de vacances
environ cent mille enfants par semaine
c'est important de rappeler cet effort
conjoint des collectivités locales et de
l'état et nous avons dans le temps donc
préparé le déconfinement qui a qui
reposait tout particulièrement sur un
renforcement de la stratégie tester
alerté protégé qui connaît en quelque
sorte une troisième étape en sept années
2020 21 puisqu'il ya eu une première
étape avec les tests antigénique au
premier trimestre qui ont été décisifs
pour nous permettre de mettre en place
cette stratégie est donc fermer des
classes chaque fois que c'était
nécessaire
jamais plus de 0,2 0,3 pour cent
delà du pays et rompre les chaînes de
contamination j'en profite pour dire que
quand on a les écoles ouvertes c'est
aussi l'occasion de plus testé les
enfants et donc de plus rompre les
chaînes de contamination la deuxième
génération de tests ça a été les tests
salivaires au deuxième trimestre qui
nous ont permis notamment d'aller
beaucoup plus à l'école primaire est
d'atteindre autour de 250 entre 250000
et 300 mille tests hebdomadaires avant
les avant le départ de du mois d'avril
et puis s'ajoute une troisième catégorie
d et désormais que sont les autotests
qui ne se substitue pas au test
salivaire mais vient de s'ajouter aux
formules précédentes et c'est dans ce
contexte donc dans la semaine du 26
avril
il ya eu le retour des élèves des écoles
primaires en présence avec un protocole
sanitaire qui étaient pour l'essentiel
le même qu'avant les vacances de
printemps et nous avons retenu ce que
nous avions retenu dans la dernière
semaine qui a précédé le départ de tous
les élèves
c'est à dire la fermeture d'une classe
dès qu'il y avait un cas de
contamination
ce qui est vraiment une mesure très
stricte avec évidemment des
inconvénients c'est à dire plus de
classes fermées mais nous avons voulu
être les plus prudents possible dans
cette stratégie de d'ouverture pendant
cette semaine du 26 avril il y a eu les
premiers hôtes aux thèses qui sont
arrivés pour les adultes et qui nous a
permis d'accomplir le début de
l'engagement annoncé c'est à dire deux
auto test par semaine par par adulte et
par école engagement dans qui ceux qui
continuent encore aujourd'hui et nous
étions d'ailleurs ce ce jour du 26 avril
avec le président de la république dans
une école primaire de mots pour
constater comment les enseignants
s'approprier
cela nous avons aussi dans cette semaine
du 26 avril déployer l'enseignement à
distance pour les élèves de
l'enseignement secondaire
il y avait eu des ratés dans la semaine
qui a précédé les vacances notamment le
mardi 2 7 de cette semaine là lié on
s'en souvient à la fois à des
difficultés qu'on pouvait les
difficultés de tuyaux notamment pour les
ent régionaux et parfois départementaux
ainsi que pour le cned qui avait en plus
fait l'objet de cyberattaques
l'épreuve avait été résolu pour
l'essentiel le mercredi qui avait suivi
mais est resté certaines failles qui ont
été aux quels il a été porté remède en
lien avec les collectivités locales
de sorte que la semaine du 26 avril et
s'est caractérisée par un bon
fonctionnement de l'enseignement à
distance
je voudrais redire que ces difficultés
de contenants c'est-à-dire de tuyaux
informatiques doivent pas occulter le
fait que ce qu'il ya eu un très grand
dynamisme
quant au contenu est que justement les
professeurs étaient avait des coûts des
contenus riches des références riches et
puis une formation qui s'était beaucoup
accentué notamment au travers de
l'opérateur canopée pendant tous les
mois qui ont précédé la semaine du 26
avril elle a marqué aussi et roselyne
bachelot tient toujours à le préciser à
juste titre la reprise des enseignements
dans les conservatoires pour les élèves
de premier et deuxième cycles qui sont
inscrits en classes à horaires aménagés
de façon à préserver la cohérence de
leur leur parcours scolaire
on a donc eu une semaine du 26 avril qui
s'est bien déroulée
avec l'ensemble des enfants d'avec le
primaire qui sont bien revenus
l'enseignement à distance qui s'est
organisée de nouveau au collège et au
lycée
et puis nous avons eu le retour des
collégiens et des lycéens le 3 mai selon
des modalités que nous avions précisé
dans l'intervalle avec le premier
ministre en tenant compte au plus près
de la date de retour des circonstances
sanitaires ce qui nous a été amené à
établir là aussi quelques évolutions du
protocole sanitaire et notamment le fait
que dans 15 départements les classes de
4e et de 3e étaient en 2011 comme le
sont systématiquement tous les lycées
encore avec à l'heure actuelle
nous avons donc cet enseignement hybride
pour ces élèves là avec évidemment le
souhait de pouvoir revenir à plein de
jauge dès que ce sera possible dès que
les conditions sanitaires le permettront
en tout cas là aussi une stratégie de
tester alerté protéger reposant
notamment enfin sur les trois catégories
de test mais tout particulièrement
désormais sur les autotests donc là
aussi dans la semaine du 3 mai les
autotests sont arrivés dans les
établissements d'enseignement secondaire
à destination des adultes
c'est environ 2 millions d'autos tests
sont arrivés cette semaine la créant
donc les premières habitude sur un sujet
qui ne comporte pas tellement de
précédents jusqu'à présent donc il faut
un petit peu accoutumée tout le monde
même si c'est relativement s'il déteste
relativement simple à réaliser et sans
douleur
las avec le problème est d'ailleurs que
nous sommes allés voir comment cela se
passait dès le premier jour donc le
lundi 3 mai dans un lycée professionnel
de nancy ça a été l'occasion de voir
monter non seulement que les adultes
avaient leurs deux autres tests
hebdomadaires mais aussi qu'il préparait
pour la semaine du 10 mai l'a donc la
semaine dans laquelle nous sommes
les la manière dont cela se passerait
avec les lycéens avec bien entendu des
toute une série d'obstacles des
difficultés et de défis que je ne cache
jamais évidemment c'est à dire le fait
c'est quelque chose de nouveau que ce
n'est pas facile à faire que nous avons
des défis logistiques considérables
puisque on parle d'environ 50 millions
d'autos test à diffuser entre maintenant
et enfin entre la fin du mois d'avril et
le début du mois de juillet rappelons
qu'il ya soixante mille implantation de
l'éducation nationale et que donc il
faut non seulement acquérir cela a
conditionné sa le diffuser dans
l'ensemble des écoles et des
établissements et à la fin faire en
sorte que les adultes s'en servent chez
eux et que les élèves puissent au moins
dans un premier temps selon un modèle
qu'on appelle le modèle à l'anglais par
différenciation avec le modèle à
l'autrichienne c'est à dire un modèle où
on commence par se tester à
l'établissement et éventuellement on
peut ensuite nom n'est pas encore le
faire à la maison une fois que les
habitudes sont prises on est encore dans
les retours de terrain sur ce sujet
en dialogue avec les chefs
d'établissements qui ont dit à quel
point ça représentait un une contrainte
supplémentaire dans leur dans la vie
quotidienne des établissements ce dont
je suis complètement conscient mais ça
fait partie de ces contraintes que nous
sommes un petit peu obligé d'avoir si
justement nous voulons être de plus en
plus efficace dans la lutte contre
contre le virus donc cette nous sommes
maintenant dans cette
dans cette situation nous nous fixons
une montée en puissance donc non
seulement pour les autotests tels que je
viens de décrire mais aussi pour les
tests salivaires qui concerne l'école
primaire mais aussi le collège nous
avons sommes désormais donné comme
objectif 400 mille tests salivaires
hebdomadaire pour arriver dès que
possible à la fin d'ici à la fin du mois
de mai à 600 mille tests salivaires
hebdomadaire donc nous avons évidemment
en parallèle la stratégie de vaccination
qui concerne les professeurs avec le
développement de centres dédiés pour les
publics prioritaires
on sait que donc ces centres ont été
ouverts
là aussi au mois deux mois d'avril
qu'ils ont rencontrés à ceux relatifs
ce n'est pas négligeable ce qui s'est
passé avec environ 20000 vaccinés à ce
titre ça aurait pu être plus mais comme
pour les tests on dépend évidemment de
delà de la volonté des personnes et jeté
à dire que pour les tests on n'a pas à
100% de volonté même pour les tests
salivaires on est autour de 65% pour les
autotests on est on est pas encore à ce
taux là et s'agissant des vaccins là le
l'image du vaccin astrazeneca a un peu
nui au volontarisme
c'est d'ailleurs pour cette raison je me
suis fait vacciner moi-même à l'astra
zeneca de façon à bien dire urbi et orbi
que ce vaccin ne pose dans l'immense
majorité des cas pas de risque et en
tout cas beaucoup moins de risques que
d'autres activités comme prendre l'avion
et comme vous voyez je suis en voit peu
près en forme devant vous même si vous
avez droit de questionner ce point aussi
là s'agissant de la de la préparation
des examens et l'autre dimension de que
vous avez mentionné tout à l'heure et je
terminerai par ce coin pour laisser
ensuite la parole à ma collègue le
c'est évidemment un sujet de
préservation de l'intérêt des élèves et
c'est vraiment le critère fondamental
pour prendre les décisions que j'ai eu à
prendre chacun a vu les les
interrogations et parfois les
inquiétudes auxquelles vous avez fait
référence au fait que vous avez fait
référence à l' instant monsieur le
président s'agissant des différents
examens d'ailleurs baccalauréats général
technologique et professionnel mais
aussi ses ap et autres le bts qui relève
de la compétence de frédéric vidal ou
d'autres d'autres examens je sens retour
revenir dans le détail de ces mesures
peut-être que vos questions vous me
mènera à y revenir je vous à dire que ce
qui nous a guidé c'est la recherche de
au maximum bien sûr de l'intérêt de
l'élève qui passe à mes yeux par la
sauvegarde autant que possible d'un
minimum de base de contrôle terminal
je rappelle qu'il ya deux ans j'entends
et parfois beaucoup de contestations sur
le principe du contrôle continu
maintenant je sais un petit peu à fronts
renversés puisque les fortes pressions
pour généraliser un petit peu le
contrôle continu je pense que c'est
l'intérêt des élèves
s'agissant du baccalauréat général qui a
beaucoup attiré l'attention de d'avoir
un contrôle terminal pour vivre cette
expérience mieux se préparer à
l'enseignement supérieur
participez à la valeur du diplôme
mais c'est quand même des mesures de
grande bienveillance qui ont été prises
avec le site et de choisir la meilleure
note entre le contrôle continu de
contrôle terminal en philosophie et
s'agissant du grand oral des adaptations
notamment pour indiquer les parties du
programme qui n'auraient pas été vus
pour prendre ces mesures j'ai beaucoup
écouté les organisations syndicales
différentes organisations et tout
particulièrement les conseil national de
la vie lycéenne de façon à arriver à un
résultat qui puisse satisfaire les uns
les autres pour moi l'important c'est
que les élèves puissent être au travail
dans la période actuelle et aboutira à
la préparation la meilleure possible
dans la perspective d'une année 21 22
qui je l'espère sera beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus normal pour eux notamment
pour leur poursuite d'études voilà à
grands traits ce que je pouvais dire en
introduction mais bien sûr je suis par
définition à votre disposition pour
toutes les questions que vous voudrez
poser ministre hamad ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et sénatrices
depuis plus d'un an le sport parce qu'il
est au centre de la vie sociale est
touché en plein coeur vous l'avez dit
monsieur le président par la pandémie
que nous avons connue et que nous vivons
encore aujourd'hui
mais aujourd'hui justement nous pouvons
enfin nous projeter regarder devant nous
avec confiance et envisager une
perspective heureuse pour le sport avant
de vous présenter les grands axes de
réouverture de ce secteur je veux
exprimer ma gratitude aux trois cent
soixante mille associations sportives
pour avoir tenu bon et maintenu le lien
avec leurs adhérents
j'ai une pensée toute particulière pour
l'heure 2 millions de bénévoles que vous
représentez aussi ici au sénat pour les
éducateurs sportifs qui ont su patienter
maintenir la motivation de leurs troupes
merci aussi aux acteurs du sport des
structures privées au magasin de sport
aux clubs professionnels qui se sont
préoccupés de leurs abonnés de leurs
clients de leurs supporters pour garder
en vie la flamme qui les anime et
l'amour de la pratique sportive
plus de la moitié de la population de
notre pays m
et s'adonne à une activité sportive et
parmi ces 36 millions de pratiquantes et
pratiquant il faut avoir un regard
particulier sur les 16 millions qui
avaient l'habitude de le faire en club
pour qu'ils y reviennent rassurer et
motivés je sais que nous partageons
tous la conviction que la pratique
sportive est essentiel tant pour notre
santé physique psychologique que pour
les enjeux de cohésion sociale
d'émancipation et de santé publique qui
s'y rattachent c'est pourquoi depuis le
début du premier confinement en mars
2020 nous sommes avec jean michel
blanquer air et nos équipes du ministère
chargé des sports quotidiennement
mobilisés pour maintenir la pratique
sportive amateur et professionnel à
chaque étape nous avons veillé à
préserver au mieux le sport en plein air
pour tous nos concitoyens à le préserver
par tous pour les publics prioritaires
porteurs de handicap ou d'une
prescription médicale pour les mineurs
et bien entendu pour nos athlètes de
haut niveau ou professionnels dont le
sport la pratique et la compétition sont
le métier à cet égard je tiens à saluer
le sérieux de ces sportifs le travail
colossal déployés aussi par les
fédérations et les ligues
professionnelles et leur club pour
établir des protocoles qui respecte à la
lettre les recommandations des autorités
de santé
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs les
récentes annonces du président de la
république et du premier ministre hier
représente pour toutes et tous une
embellie
ils ont en effet fixé quatre dates clés
qui se traduisent concrètement pour le
secteur du sport
le 3 mai déjà à marquer la fin de la
limitation de déplacement ainsi que la
reprise des activités pour le scolaire
et le périscolaire dans des équipements
sportifs couverts en intérieur piscine
comprise le 19 mai prochain
nous franchirons un palier important
pour le sport puisque le public sera de
retour dans les stades et les salles
accueillant des compétitions sportives
avec un plafond de 1000 spectateurs en
extérieur 800 en intérieur maximum mais
dans le cadre de jauge proportionnelle à
l'enceinte
à ce moment là le 19 juin toujours les
activités sportives en intérieur pour
les mineurs seront à nouveau permise je
pense par exemple à l'ouverture des
piscines pour les activités
extrascolaires sujet sur lequel vous
êtes régulièrement interrogé sur vos
territoires mais nous insistons avec
jean michel blanquer pour qui également
les cycles de la natation scolaire
puisse reprendre à ce moment là les
compétitions puisque monsieur le
président vous m'avez interrogé à ce
sujet effectivement pour moi également
reprendre sans limite
sion du nombre de participants à partir
du moment où il s'agit de mineurs et
effectivement le public qui sera admis à
ce moment là dans les gradins de c2c
enceinte sportive sera limitée par les
limites en vigueur qui seront de 800
personnes en intérieur s'il s'agit d'une
piscine par exemple le 9 juin 2021
marquera une nouvelle grande étape à
savoir le retour du public dans les
stades jusqu'à 5000 personnes sur
présentation d'un pass sanitaire c'est
effectivement là que entrera en jeu se
passe sanitaire qui va être discutée
prochainement avec tous les
parlementaires et auquel nos acteurs du
sport sont particulièrement positifs à
l'égard de ce pass sanitaires aussi bien
pour les spectateurs que pour les
pratiquants mais nous pourrons peut-être
revenir au moment où vous nous poserait
des questions il y aura le 9 juin la
réouverture des salles de sport privé
laisser salle de fitness qui ont aussi
beaucoup souffert pendant cette cette
période parce qu'elles n'ont été
ouvertes que dans des périodes creuses
pour elle économiquement parlant et qu'
elles craignent que les personnes se
soient dirigés vers des pratiques plus
tôt individuelle et qu'elle ait du mal à
revenir dans les salles de sport
enfin l'élargissement de la pratique
sportive au sport de contact en plein
air ainsi qu'aux sports en salle sans
qu'il ne puisse y avoir de contact pour
les adultes à ce moment là le 30 juin
alors que le couvre feu sera levé nous
visons la fin des limites de jauge selon
la situation sanitaire locale dans les
établissements en relevant recevant du
public ainsi que l'élargissement de
l'accueil de tout événement avec plus de
1000 personnes sur présentation d'un
pass sanitaires nous avons ainsi
souhaité une réouverture progressive
prudente et responsable avec un retour à
une vie sociale par étapes
sachant s'adapter aux situations locales
et à l'évolution du contexte épidémique
car comme vous notre responsabilité nous
oblige si nous assumons faire des choix
nous devons nous nous devons de toujours
préserver la santé des françaises et des
français
cette progressivité nous l'avons
réfléchi et travaillé en concertation
avec les acteurs du monde sportif et
nous partageons avec eux l'objectif de
la pérennité de ces mesures tant pour
les pratiquants que
pour le public je souhaite rappeler que
sous l'impulsion de notre ministère les
fédérations sportives les acteurs
économiques du sport les collectivités
locales et les acteurs de l'état
travaillent ensemble depuis plus d'un an
à raison d'une réunion hebdomadaire de
leurs représentants et sous la forme le
groupe de travail organisé par notre
ministère nous avons élaboré ensemble
des protocoles sanitaires qui permette
la reprise progressive dans les
meilleures conditions techniques et de
sécurité par exemple avec lempdes nous
avons nous leur avons fait produire et
réfléchir à des guides qui met en avant
les conditions d'accès et d'utilisation
des équipements sportifs pour les
pratiquants comme pour le public et vous
êtes des maillons essentiels des
territoires et je souhaite que vous
puissiez partir participer activement à
ce travail de partage des informations
auprès de nos concitoyens parce que
c'est vrai que les interprétations des
mesures sont parfois inégale sur les
territoires mais nous avons désormais
pris attache direct avec les préfets
pour que nous puissions les aider à
interpréter le plus précisément possible
les mesures qui sont annoncées et pas
souvent autant dans le détail que je
peux le faire aujourd'hui devant vous je
voulais revenir sur les efforts
financiers sans précédent du
gouvernement pour aider ce secteur
sportif dans toutes ses dimensions
professionnels amateurs et loisirs
marchand vous le savez le sport
bénéficie d'un plan de relance
sectoriels doté de 122 millions d'euros
la moitié consacrée à l'emploi sportif
des jeunes
le plan de relance est en train de se
déployer en particulier grâce au
concours de l' agence nationale du sport
et des services déconcentrés de notre
ministère dans le cadre du comité
interministériel de la ville en janvier
dernier 36 millions d'euros
supplémentaires vont être confiées à
l'agent ce pour développer les
équipements sportifs et soutenir les
associations dans les quartiers
prioritaires
ces crédits nouveaux ont vocation à
permettre le rattrapage d'un manque
d'équipements sur certains territoires à
diversifier leur nature dans un même
bassin de vie à développer les actions
d'insertion par le sport tout en
contribuant à la diffusion des savoirs
fondamentaux que nous voulons voir plus
aux mains des professeurs des écoles dès
l'école maternelle
au-delà de ces enveloppes
complémentaires l' agence nationale du
sport
accorde systématiquement dans le
déploiement de ses actions une attention
particulière aux territoires les plus
fragiles
l'équipe tv mais aussi les zones de
revitalisation rurale enfin dans
l'optique du soutien aux robots de la
pratique tout en garantissant la
sécurité des pratiquants nous avons
activement participé ces derniers mois
avec jean michel blanquer à aux travaux
visant à l'élaboration d'un masque
adapté à toute pratique sportive
notre ministère a contribué au
financement des travaux de l'afnor pour
réaliser cette norme utile aux
fabricants pour avoir ce masque
barrières pour le sport le référentiel a
été publié en février dernier les
industriels ont déjà lancé les chaînes
de fabrication certaines salles de sport
les auront déjà à disposition des
pratiquants au moment de l'ouverture et
désormais il est aussi disponible chez
certains fabricants
enfin nous finalisons les modalités
opérationnelles du déploiement du
passeport ce dispositif qui va permettre
une aide à la prise de licence et
d'adhésion sportive sur nos territoires
ce dispositif sera doté de 100 millions
d'euros
déployée dès cette année et évidemment
toutes ces aides sectorielles
spécifiques aux sports s'ajoute aux 3 5
milliards d'euros déjà déployé
aujourd'hui dans notre secteur sportif
par les mesures de droit commun dont ont
bénéficié tous les acteurs du monde
sportif associatif fédéraux économique
du sport
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs s'il
est de notre devoir de rester prudent
les perspectives sont encourageantes
aussi plus que jamais au sortir de la
crise nous allons avoir besoin des clubs
et associations sportives des éducateurs
des bénévoles pour mettre les citoyens
en mouvement partout et recréer ce lien
social entre tous dans le strict respect
toujours des règles sanitaires qui sont
encore aujourd'hui en vigueur
merci estimé la ministre nous avons
passé une première série de questions de
la part de nora porter en commençant par
jacques grosperrin rapporteur des
crédits enseignement scolaire et en
s'écriant jacques lozach rapporteur des
crédits pour le sport merci président
madame la ministre monsieur le ministre
alors une étude récente de ram c'est
santé montrent qu'il ya deux jeunes sur
trois qui ont des pensées suicidaires du
morcellement aux réseaux sociaux et à la
solitude
pourrais je dis cela parce que le
confinement les différents types de
confinement montré une grande
solitude donc l'urgence psychiatrique
est véritablement réel et c'est vrai que
le repli sur la cellule familiale a pu
renforcer ce sentiment d'isolement qui
est particulièrement encouragés par
l'utilisation des réseaux sociaux et
c'est vrai que c'est une génération qui
est très adepte ou en tout cas les
agiles par rapport à cela donc si c'est
ma première question est ce que vos
ministères avez vous eu une attitude ou
une politique particulière vis-à-vis de
cette prévention vise à lisser réseaux
sociaux qui sont particulièrement
développées dans une période de
confinement ma deuxième question
tournera autour des des cours intensifs
est ce qu'on peut s'interroger est ce
que vous êtes interrogé sur la
certainement d'ailleurs avant le début
de l'année prochaine sur des cours de
rattrapage en quelque sorte que qu'on
pourrait mettre en place vis-à-vis de de
ces générations de d'enfants même si le
présentiel ou en tout cas le distanti
elles existent je pense qu'il ya
peut-être aussi une réflexion mais je ne
lui pas que vous avez dû la voir parce
que c'est toujours le même cas il ya des
enfants dans des familles plus
privilégiés qui auront la possibilité de
pouvoir faire intervenir des des
intervenants extérieurs sur les
autotests j'ai bien entendu monsieur le
ministre les grands difficultés j'ai
apprécié lorsque vous avez dit que la
particulier une unité française c'était
que l'école a pu continuer
je crois que ça je peux tout le monde
ici peu plus en féliciter est-ce qu'ils
étaient bien aussi si vous avez ajouté
avec des imperfections
je crois que c'est important aussi de
faire preuve d'humilité parce que c'est
quelque chose qui est tellement
singulier est tellement difficile qu'on
peut s'imaginer que d'être à votre place
ça doit être très compliqué mais il ya
une logistique a été importante mais la
logistique ça n'arrive pas toujours et
les premiers d'acheminement on se rend
compte que il reste plus qu'un mois de
cours est ce que c'était vraiment utile
parce que c'était vraiment utile
lorsqu'on sait que ça prend cinquante
huit heures par semaine lorsque ça prend
ça me rend difficile les chefs
d'établissement lorsqu'il ça pose le
problème du consentement du non
consentement
lorsqu'on n'arrive pas à les chefs
d'établissement vous le dise il n'arrive
pas à avoir le consentement des parents
et puis il faut aussi des parents ou en
tout cas ce lorsqu'ils sont majeurs des
élèves parce qu'elle a qui veulent le
faire est ce que cdt véritablement pas
ce qu'on n'a pas mis en place une ixième
à gaz procès
donnez interpellé vis-à-vis de cela je
voudrais ensuite une quatrième question
c'est sûr les élèves handicapés
lorsqu'on parle d'inclusion et on sait
qu'en ce moment on leur dit de rester
justement d'inclusion pour pas les mêler
en tout cas le maître dans ce qu'on
appelle ce brassage qui peut être
générateur de deux d'accélération de
cette pandémie sur le remplacement je
terminerai pas sur le remplacement des
profs mais lorsqu'un prof est absent
qu'est-ce qu'on fait des élèves on nous
dit qu'il faut pas placer les élèves
dans d'autres classes parce que il ya
aussi ce problème les difficultés donc
on se trouvent dans des situations et
c'est tout un ensemble de questions je
souhaiterais vous poser enfin sur
l'adaptation du bac du de la philo du
bac s qu'on n'aurait pas pu avoir un
parallélisme entre les preuves de la
philo du bac et l'épreuve du français du
premier qu'est ce qu'on pourrait passer
ça réfléchit à pêcher par rapport à ça
et enfin moi je voudrais avoir un petit
coup de gueule sur l'attitude la double
tout cas l'attitude sur des syndicats
qui se réjouissent de vos échecs mais
qui sont nos échecs à nous tous qui sont
les échecs comment donner
elle ne peut pas accepter cela alors on
entend qu'il parle qu'il ya des
personnels eu de danger de trop de
présentiel etc
je sens que le ministère aussi
favorisent une paix sociale
je sens le ministère aussi faire en
sorte que les lycéens parce qu'on n'est
pas à l'abri d'un mouvement des lycéens
il faut que le désamorcer mais j'espère
que le grenelle de l'environnement
permettra de casser tout cela parce que
l'attitude très singulière grande
difficulté nakheel
tout le monde a été placée mais en même
temps je tiens quand même à vous rendre
hommage vis-à-vis de de travail qui a
été fait et du fait de cette singularité
française comme je disais au départ je
crois que c'est courage de le faire et
c'est peut-être pour ça aussi qu'il ya
beaucoup prenez aussi en même temps
merci jean jacques lozach
oui merci monsieur le président ce
ministre de ministres sur les conditions
la reprise sanitaire groupe et
d'activités dans le sport de biens
saisis l'échéancier c'est à dire ces
trois dates 19 mai 9 juin 30 juin avec
de façon très très schématique partir du
19 mai les mineurs qui vont reprendre
leurs activités comme avant la pandémie
même chose pour les plus de 18 ans à
partir du 30 juin et puis entre les deux
je dirais cette évolution concernant les
piscines les stades les salles de sport
le 9 juin avec cette jauge à 50% bon la
difficulté de compréhension bien
évidemment c'est dans les détails si je
peux dire dans la diversité des
situations les choses qui évoluent les
protocoles les spécificités des
événements et c'est bon vous l'avez dit
vous-même d'ailleurs une étude de
rappeler qu'on est fortement sollicité
par tous les acteurs du sport
les clubs les ligues et les fédérations
les organisateurs d'événements les
loisirs marchands etc et nous
sollicitent d'ailleurs soit de manière
isolée si je peux dire soit de façon
plus collective plus concertée et je
vais prendre un exemple c'est la reprise
des manifestations sportives outdoor
comme on dit un dd d'extérieur pour
savoir ce qui encore négociable ou pas à
ce stade sur ses activités soit en
matière d'exigences moins contraignante
aux dates des 9 et 30 juin prochains
concernant les conditions la reprise des
aides aux organisateurs et c'est par
exemple à partir du 9 juin
on voit d'un côté que pour les
événements culturels on aura une jauge à
5000 personnes en intérieur alors que
pour les évènements sportifs outdoor
eh bien on aura une limitation à cinq
cents participants et non pas cinq piles
et ont des portants en extérieur donc
est ce qu'il n'ya pas une correction à
apporter pour aller vers semble-t-il
davantage de cohérence
une deuxième question en 2020 donc à
l'occasion de cette pandémie tas par une
innovation cette innovation c'était le
déploiement du dispositif deux aces de
c1 se déroulant sur sur le temps
scolaire et à l'initiative des
collectivités locales c'est un
dispositif qui permet de tisser des
liens plus étroits entre la psa l'école
et puis d'autre part le tissu associatif
sur des savoir si la vocation à être
pérennisées
au delà de la crise sanitaire et dans
combien de communes il a été mise en
place
et puis pour faire le lien si je peux
dire entre l'été 2020 et l'été 2021 qui
approche une question analogues mais sur
les vacances apprenantes qui concerne
aussi la dimension physique et sportive
est-ce que ce dispositif là va être
reconduit pour pour l'été prochain
et si oui cette fois ci avec l montant
de financement alloué puisque l'an
dernier avait été débloqué 200 millions
d'euros sur le pass'sport une petite
demande de précisions vous avez rappelé
tout à l'heure votre volonté de
l'appliquer rapidement avec la
confirmation du montant financier qui
avait été annoncé par le président de la
république au mois de novembre c'est à
dire 100 millions d'euros simplement une
demande de précisions sur vraiment le
public qui va être concernées sur les
conditions de ressources aussi
j'évite le séno et demander notamment
parce que les familles bénéficiaires de
l'allocation de rentrée scolaire
perçoivent le pass'sport enfin et là
aussi vous êtes sollicité bien
évidemment c'est sur les clubs amateurs
que professionnels et sur les clubs
professionnels concernant on parle
beaucoup du football mais pas simplement
le football ensemble des sports
collectifs va arriver en débat bientôt
un projet de loi de finances
rectificative donc je voudrais savoir si
de nouvelles aides sont envisagés dans
ce plfr
au-delà des aides de droit commun que
vous avez rappelé il ya un instant
madame madame la ministre
voilà et puis je m'échappe et un petit
peu m'en voudrez pas du déconfinement
pour poser la question incontournable à
savoir quand arrivera en débat au sénat
la future loi sur est sûre la
démocratisation du sport qui est passé
au mois de mars à l'assemblée nationale
merci je voulais c'est répondre à cette
première salle est question des
blessures y en aura d'autres par la
suite
merci monsieur le président donc je vais
répondre évidemment question du sénateur
groupe eramet et à une question du
sénateur lozach le sur la question de la
prévention de des risques il ya avec les
réseaux sociaux et notamment du fait que
depuis le couple premier confinement il
ya eu évidemment un développement très
important de cette fréquentation des
réseaux sociaux
c'est un sujet très difficile puisque
lorsqu'on voit un phénomène de société
mondiale qui est qu'il est difficile de
prendre pleinement à bras le corps nous
nous avons vous le savez une politique
de lutte contre le harcèlement et le
cyberharcèlement très volontariste sais
pas d'ailleurs le seul sujet par rapport
aux problèmes que vous évoquez
et pour commencer par celui là et depuis
maintenant trois ans que nous avons sept
cette politique nous rencontrons deux
premiers résultats vraiment intéressant
en matière de lutte contre le
harcèlement
nous avons fait baisser les chiffres du
harcèlement scolaire etc
point très important en revanche nous
rencontrons des limites dans la lutte
contre le cyber harcèlement
parce que même si nous réussissons à le
combattre
il se déploie malgré tout et nous allons
devoir peut-être passer à un stade plus
fort encore de lutte alors je vais pas
vous établir l'ensemble des choses qui
sont faites elles sont nombreuses mais
il faut avoir à l'esprit évidemment tous
les enjeux de formation des enjeux de
partenariat avec les associations commis
en france comme d'autres associations
qui travaillent sur ces sur ces
questions comme la maison de marion par
exemple tout c'est toutes ces
associations travaillent de plus en plus
avec le ministère de l'éducation
nationale y compris pour faire des
sessions de formation dans les
établissements sur le sur l'usagé
d'internet en général
l'éducation aux médias est un point qui
se développe lui aussi pas seulement
avec le clemi mais de façon générale a
aussi avec la formation des professeurs
que que nous faisons donc l'opérateur
canopée développer des formations à
distance pour les professeurs sur ce
sujet de l'éducation à internet
mais on doit reconnaître que cette
période qui favorise les usages
numériques comporte des aspects positifs
indubitable c'est à dire un très grand
développement qualitatif
de l'enseignement à distance et nous
avons développé des ressources
considérables
je pense aussi que l'unique est
maintenant un grand succès public et
c'est ainsi que nous avons conçu avec
france télévisions le ministère de la
culture qui me permet aujourd'hui
d'avoir une très grande richesse de
ressources mais mais symétriquement il
ya toute une série de dérives alors à
signaler au passage que l'interdiction
des téléphones portables au collège est
quelque chose qui fonctionne et qui a
porté des fruits important mais ça mais
ça n'est pas ce n'est pas évidemment
l'unique réponse sur la question des
cours intensifs alors à la rentrée
dernière nous avons
développer une série d'outils pour
rattraper ce qui était nécessaire il ya
eu les postes créés dans le premier
degré il ya eu les heures
supplémentaires dans le second degré
notamment pour développer le dispositif
devoirs faits et les skis accompagnement
personnalisé pour la rentrée prochaine
nous développons aussi de
l'accompagnement personnalisé au travers
des heures supplémentaires ce qui est
d'ailleurs visible dans nos documents
budgétaires set mais ce qui est certain
c'est que plus que jamais le mot d'ordre
et personnalisation des parcours
capacité à identifier les difficultés
d'où l'intérêt par exemple de nos
évaluations de début d'année comme les
évaluations de cp et de ce1 de 6e ou
même de seconde qui permettent de
déclencher ce cet accompagnement
personnalisé sur les autotests vous avez
posé la question de
vous avez dit était ce vraiment utile
alors évident je met ça en regard de
débats qui avaient avant et qui était
qui souvent consiste à dire mais
pourquoi ne faites vous pas les autres
thèses savoir que nos amis autrichiens
ou anglais le fond donc c'est assez
typique du type de débat que l'on a
c'est à dire qu'on avait beaucoup de
critiques sur le fait de ne pas utiliser
à plein le système d auto tel c'est
maintenant qu'ils sont là beaucoup de
critiques sur les inconvénients qu'ils
représentent
alors je pense que c'est vraiment utile
parce que c'est encore une fois une
étape supplémentaire ça ne remplace pas
d'ailleurs les autres catégories de
tests qui se déploie au travers de ce
que nous faisons non seulement nous
contribuons à la stratégie tester alerté
protéger donc à rompre les chaînes de
contamination méthode quand même pour
lesquelles nous avons été nous les
français plutôt bon depuis le mois de
septembre c'était à la coopération
commissaire de la santé c'est à dire les
agences régionales de santé et les
rectorats a permis d'être dynamique sur
cette capacité à être réactif sur le
terrain pour rompre les chaînes de
contamination mais cette
7 cette première phase nécessité d'être
complétée par la phase actuelle est donc
non seulement il s'agit de se renforcer
dans notre capacité à remplir chaîne de
contamination mais aussi à créer des
habitudes donc une dimension pédagogique
chez les élèves pour pour les temps
futurs pour les mois qui viennent en
matière de co vide et de façon générale
pour les enjeux d'éventuelles épidémies
d'e des temps futurs
c'est aussi une nouvelle culture de
résilience pendant les crises sanitaires
qui ce qui se déploie le
vous m'avez posé la question aussi des
de ce que nous faisons pour les examens
en matière dont deux français en
comparant cela ce qui se passera en
philosophie donc je voudrais rappliquer
des amines et des aménagements dans les
deux cas mais qui sont un peu différents
s'agissant de la philosophie
le raisonnement qui nous a amenés à
faire le choix entre contrôle continu et
contrôle terminal
en allant un peu au delà même des
revendications puisqu'elle était de
faire le contrôle continu et nous sommes
partis du principe que c'était bon
d'avoir un contrôle terminal et que
c'était bon que les élèves qui par
exemple avait eu des mauvaises notes en
contrepartie du puy se rattraper à
l'occasion du contrôle terminal mais
avec la spécificité de la philosophie
qui est la seule discipline que l'on
apprend sur une année on commence en
terminale et qu'on finit en terminale
est ce qui fait que lorsqu'on a eu une
année parfois hachuré comme ça a pu
arriver pour non pas pour tous les
lycéens mais pour certains lycéens il ya
de réelles difficultés à se sentir
pleinement près
sur la seule base à l'examen terminal en
revanche le français comme d'autres
disciplines mais tout particulièrement
le français vient vient consacrer un
parcours qui a commencé depuis depuis
l'école primaire
et puis nous avons pris des mesures
adaptées pour le français qui correspond
d'ailleurs des demandes de certaines
organisations
c'est à dire de doubler le nombre de
sujets c'est à dire que tout élève aura
le choix entre six sujets non pas trois
mais 6 ce qui rend pratiquement
impossible de faire des impasses ou de
se trouver dans une situation où aucun
sujet ne me convient encore une fois le
but c'est aussi de permettre à chaque
élève de s'exercer
et je crois qu'il ya une relative
satisfaction de la position d' équilibre
que nous avions eue si nous avions le
contrôle continu absolue partout je
pense que il pourrait y avoir deux
symétriquement de nouveaux reproches qui
viendrait de priver les élèves de ce2 ce
moment si particulier qu'est le
baccalauréat et le contrôle terminal le
vous avez fait référence au grenelle de
l'éducation pour faire un appel à
l'intérêt général dont je ne peux que
vous remercier le grenelle de la coupe
ducation arrive à maturité maintenant et
donc c'est au cours de ce mode mais que
nous avons vocation à donner certaines
conclusions qui d'ailleurs démontre que
pendant la crise qu vide les réformes se
poursuivent
parfois elles peuvent être un peu
retardé un peu gêné bien sûr mais
l'objectif de d'améliorer la
rémunération des professeurs demeure
hélas l'objectif de transformation de la
gestion des ressources humaines sur la
base de concertation très large et de
travaux très approfondies qui ont eu
lieu et continue est poursuivi et va se
concrétiser
vous le verrez dans l'est dans les tout
prochains temps et aussi avec les
premières augmentation tangible dès dès
ce mois de mai pour les professeurs les
plus jeunes j'aurai l'occasion d'y
revenir certainement dans d'autres
contextes
merci d'avoir souligné que c'était
important d'avoir et même crucial
d'avoir maintenu les écoles ouvertes et
merci d'avoir dit que ça devrait être un
sujet de l'unité entre nous tous d'entre
tous les français c'est vrai que dans la
traversée de cette crise parfois
on peut regretter que certaines
polémiques soit excessive alors même que
c'est d'unité pour nous devons faire
preuve nous nous soumettons évidemment
au débat démocratique c'est ce qu'on
fait en ce moment même mais par exemple
le succès qui est saluée
internationalement de l'ouverture des
écoles je devrai faire le jeu d'une
fierté collective
parce que c'est porteur d'avenir la
france je l'espère et je le pense va
être en situation d'avoir évité le 'trou
d'air' éducatif qui malheureusement va
caractériser beaucoup de pays dans les
temps qui viennent je l' ai déjà dit
devant vous je pense que nous devons
prendre des initiatives de nature
européenne et internationale par rapport
à conséquence de société et de
géopolitique grave qui vont naître dans
les temps à venir à l'échelle mondiale
de ce trou d'air éducatif mais en tout
cas s'agissant de la france nous aurons
je crois traverser ce cap horn avec des
problèmes bien sûr encore une fois
reconnaissons-le et des améliorations
encore nécessaire bien sûr mais malgré
tout l'essentiel préserver c'est à dire
la possibilité pour les élèves d'aller
d'aller à l'école
je réponds rapidement à un point de ce
qu'a dit le sénateur lozach et bien sûr
je passe la parole à à ma collègue c'est
ce que vous avez dit sur deux aces de
ces sur les vacances à prenantes
c'est un sujet sur lequel notre union
avec roxana maracineanu et donc le fait
d'avoir un ministère dé la jeu de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse et
des sports produit des effets positifs
nous en sommes tous les deux très très
heureux avec bien d'autres pour parce
que ces synergies
porte des fruits il ya les sujets dont
on parle pas nécessairement dans deux
cadres d'aujourd'hui mais comme les 30
minutes d'activité physique à l'école
primaire comme la naissance maintenant
de delà de l'enseignement de spécialité
éducation physique et sportive dans le
cadre de la réforme du lycée et dès la
rentrée prochaine
c'était jeudi dernier dans un lycée de
moulins qui par exemple va le faire
toutes ces sujets sont des produits de
notre désormais dans notre travail
je dirais fusionnelle entre le sport et
l'éducation nationale puisque nous
sommes un même ministère ce qui accélère
et facilite bien des choses et
s'agissant de deux aces 2 c l'année
dernière c'était un processus en urgence
que nous avions élaboré pour que les
élèves et des activités éducatives
même quand ils n'étaient pas accueillis
à l'école cela a été très fructueux pour
ceux qui l'ont vécue qui sont restés une
minorité au ccdh un rapport flash de
l'assemblée nationale a établi s'ils
étaient moins de 10% mais néanmoins là
où ça s'est passé ça s'est bien passé ça
a eu des fruits est notamment l'un des
fruits a été que ça à préparer
professionnellement et
organisationnellement a créé à être
prêts pour vacances apprenantes et deux
aces de ces a aussi été un tremplin de
vacances apprenons donc nous avions bien
dit que deux aces de ça et pas vocation
à se reproduire tel quel par la suite
mes parts on a créé des habitudes de
travail
et des réflexes qui eux ont perduré en
2020 21 et nous restons ouverts à
élaborer et des sortes de nouveau deux
aces de ces pour les temps à venir à
quelque chose qui succède à deux
aces de ces qui en tire les fruits et
s'agissant des vacances à prenantes
là aussi nous serons amenés avec roxana
maracineanu mais aussi avec le ministre
et d'autres ministres a été bien le
cadre général très très prochainement de
façon à à avancer mais voyez hier
j'étais je terminerai par cette anecdote
mais c'est important d'être concret
parfois et de donner des illustrations
j'étais avec le président la république
dans votre jardin le jardin du
luxembourg hier
pour la commémoration du 10 mai donc de
l'abolition de l'esclavagé et le
la et deux enfants qui étaient là de
clichy sous bois sont venus voir de
collégiens en me disant est ce qu'il y
aura les vacances apprenant de cette
année parce que c'était drôlement bien
l'année dernière je crois que on a là un
objectif social absolument fondamental
et l'agent répondu oui bien sûr comme je
vous le répète on l'a on a un objectif
social fondamental qui l'année dernière
a touché un million d'élèves et on
espère faire encore mieux cette année au
travers de dispositifs d'ailleurs qu'ils
seront très variés et que nous
présenterons très prochainement et qui
sont là aussi synergies très forte entre
le produit d'une synergie très forte
entre plusieurs acteurs mais notamment
sur l'éducation nationale du sport et
des collectivités locales
effectivement quand comme l'a dit
monsieur le ministre la sur le deux aces
de ses vacances apprenantes nos acteurs
ont appris à collaborer ensemble les
fédérations sportives vont se mobiliser
activement et les associations pour
aller sur juillet-août aussi proposé la
suite des activités sportives ou le
rattrapage qui n'a pas pu être fait
pendant l'année pour leurs adhérents
mais aussi aller chercher d'autres
adhérents c'est aussi l'objectif du
passeport que vous avez évoqué monsieur
lozach qui outre le fait de venir en
soutien aux associations avec ses 100
millions d'euros a comme objectif de
mettre plus en lien les établissements
scolaires avec leur association de
territoire les associations qui les
entourent déjà pour parler de ce
dispositif aux familles qui vont en
bénéficier nous ciblons pour notre
par mon ministère des sports c'était les
discussions qui avait eu à l'époque avec
le mouvement sportif des familles plus
tôt avec un coefficient familial de 600
euros
après discussion avec le mouvement
sportif à nouveau nous allons élargir
cette assiette mais sans pouvoir aller
jusqu à l'allocation de rentrée scolaire
qui toucherait 5 millions d'enfants et
nous n'avons aujourd'hui nous avons
l'envié de faire des réductions
conséquentes sur l'adhésion est donc
allé jusqu'à un montant qui permettra
aux jeunes de s'inscrire voire d'avoir
la gratuité de leur inscription sportive
en comptant aussi sur des cofinancements
avec des collectivités sportives voire
des fédérations qui compte aussi mettre
au pot à cet argent débloqué par l'état
pour qu'un certain nombre d'enfants
conséquent puissent avoir accès
quasiment gratuitement à des activités
sportives l'année prochaine dans
notamment dans les culs pv mais pas que
également aussi dans les haies derrière
on trouve ces familles par rapport aux
effectivement la précision des de la
jauge alors ce qu'il faut bien saisir
c'est que dans le champ sportif il ya
deux sortes de george hill à la jauge
spectateurs qui est là même finalement
pour les événements sportifs et
culturels de 5000 à partir du 9 juin
néanmoins effectivement il ya cette
jauge de pratiquants qui sont quelque
part un peu les organisateurs
incontournable d'un événement puisque
sans eux il n'y a pas d'événements
sportifs et pour préserver aussi leur
santé puisque la pratique sportive de
masse va se faire sans masque même si
c'est à l'extérieur il y aura toujours
des rassemblements au départ à l'arrivée
donc effectivement on à désirer revenir
progressivement à décider des événements
de masse conséquent pour le mois de
juillet août pour que ça puisse se faire
de manière pérenne et donc dans ces deux
mois qui nous séparent la de l'été on
souhaite que ce soit progressif avec une
jauge de compétitions en extérieur sur
l'espace public de 50 personnes puis de
2500 personnes et enfin de 5000
personnes après le 30 juin mais il
s'agit bien de d'une dune comment dire
d'une organisation des compétitions
différentes puisque ce seront des blocs
de 50 pers
à nous de 2500 personnes qui pour
comprendre les départs et donc on est en
train de regarder avec les organisateurs
d'événements sportifs
comment agencer ces compétitions
différemment pour que ces gens ne se
croise pas mais qu'on reste dans quelque
chose de deux sécuritaire pour les
pratiquants puisque encore une fois ils
vont pratiquer sans avoir le masque
alors que dans les rp circulant comme
les musées comme les comme les foires et
salons qui sont elles autorisées à avoir
5000 personnes dans ces établissements
dès le 9 juin il s'est enfin voilà on
portera le masque on sera à distance
enfin sur
avec votre question je voulais moi aussi
revenir sur ce que vous avez dit
monsieur grosperrin sur le effectivement
l'attention qu'on porte aux jeunes qui
aujourd'hui sont happés par les réseaux
sociaux nous avons mandaté et financé
plusieurs associations pour qu'elles
fassent aussi le tour des établissements
sportifs que sont les crêtes venir leur
parler de tous ces sujets de société en
plus de leur pratique sportive et ce
pour quoi ils sont dans l'est dans ses
crêpes souvent hébergés en internat et
notamment un partenariat que nous avons
avec une association qui s'appelle
respect zone qui insiste beaucoup sur le
harcèlement le cyber harcèlement en
ligne et qui tout particulièrement
pendant cette période a fait des
webinaires et des interventions dans ces
creps puisque les jeunes étaient
hébergés et pratiquer leur leur activité
sportive voilà et puis bien sûr sur la
loi vous m'avez posé la question moi je
suis ravi de voir que le sujet intéresse
le sénat c'est effectivement ce que je
souhaite et c'est en ce sens que
j'échange aujourd'hui avec le
gouvernement pour qu'on puisse ensemble
trouver une loi enfin pouvoir faire
passer cette loi ici au sénat et je suis
ravi de voir que ce soit les sénateurs
les parlementaires mais aussi le
mouvement sportif qui sont très
intéressés par le passage de cette loi
et son vote
ici au sénat vous êtes très nombreux à
vous être inscrits donc je vais vous
demander d'être concis pour permettre
ensuite au ministre de répondre une
exposition marot marque n'était pas
spécialement pour le premier intervenant
je vais essayer de répondre réseau mains
du président d'abord de mes questions
pour toros aux s'adressant surtout ne se
ministres éducation nationale madame
unissent ministre voudrait bien sûr mais
aussi me réjouir qu on l'a tous fait
d'abord de la grippe sont françaises et
qui fait que les élèves vont vraiment
quelle école que dans d'autres pays
d'europe où faut le reconnaître et de
dire me être heureux de voir le retour
vers l'école lycée le collège qui le
travail être un petit peu surpris de
certains mouvements qui ont pu marquer
des établissements refusant le les
épreuves
largement favoris les épreuves
terminales
je suis persuadé que les mêmes eaux été
mis dans la rue si vous aviez préconisé
de développer le contrôle continu et il
a trop bien deux ans donc c'est assez
surprenant quand même et ses pratiques
et malheureusement ce sont les élèves
qui sont largement instrumentalisée qui
sont des victimes tout soda et je
voulais le dénoncer vous avez établi un
équilibre il est ce qu'il est vous
l'avez expliqué tout à l'heure je pense
qu'on peut en prendre acte et que vous
avez trouvé un équilibre intéressant
entre et des épreuves terminales et la
nécessité vers le coton continue moi je
voudrais au delà de ces points poser de
trois questions
d'abord concernant la vaccination vous
avez parlé d'un succès relatif se
quittant la bouche d'un ministre est
déjà le signe que les choses ne sont pas
aussi satisfaisante que l'on pourrait
attendre
moi de mon terrain du terrain le constat
suivant les agents de collectivités
territoriales dans les écoles sont
souvent plus fac ci n'est que les
enseignants et donc il ya quand même qui
peu une surprise sur le sujet les
enseignants sont contactables visé est
bien plus que les agents des
collectivités territoriales donc je
pense qu'il ya là un retard vous l'avait
pointé un instant il serait bon je pense
de réduire les les appréhensions
vis-à-vis de la vaccination
d'abord aucune autre pays j'ai le même
accès que vous dans les veines nous
porterons fort bien vous et moi monsieur
le ministre mais le voila je pense qu'il
est nécessaire de donner un coup de
collier pour que l'on puisse terminer
l'année en toute sérénité
deuxièmement des remplaçants les
remplacements des professeurs
je pense qu'il ya eu des difficultés
je ne vais pas vous mais pas encore sur
le sujet je pense que plus qu'à passer
les remplacements étaient adeptes le
temps mon département passe dans le
directeur académique a remercié les
maires lors du dernier conseil
d'administration de la société mère
parce que c'est souvent les agents des
collectivités qui ont accueilli les
élèves n'ont pas fait et on peut fait
classe bien sûr mais quand tu es cuit
or c'est quelque chose qui doit être
bien sûr exceptionnel on sera d'accord
avec vous
ça pose je crois la question des
remplacements surtout donc dans les
écoles primaires
cela renvoie aussi un petit peu à
épuisement des enseignants et le manque
d'attractivité vous avez vous conduirez
coopérant en disant que les réformes
continuent et que le problème de
revalorisation des professeurs rester en
cours j'ai lu comme vous devant j'ai vu
certaines réactions syndicales qui
annoncé que cela pourrait être remis en
cause d'autant qu'est ce que vous pouvez
devant le sénat re préciser clairement
les choses
et puis est ce qu'on peut penser que
dans un agenda législatif ou recharger
la loi de programmation sur la
colonisation des enseignants va arriver
dans l'es2 et deux chambres où est ce
que ça sera à nouveau
source de débats lors des prochaines
élections présidentielles alors que vous
aviez quand même annoncé une loi de
programmation dernier point oui il ya eu
un retour il ya eu un maintien de
l'école il ya eu autour aujourd'hui vers
l'école il n'empêche qu'on peut craindre
que la question de l'obligation scolaire
et recule et que l'on puisse craindre
malgré tout que sept rapports
particuliers qui existe entre l'école et
les familles qui est un rapport aussi
très particulier à la france ont été
dégradés pendant ces deux années
est ce que vous envisagez un petit peu
dans
par des campagnes de communication ou
sida dans la formation des professeurs
des personnels de direction de rappeler
l'importance de ce rapport à l'école de
l'obligation scolaire
de même est ce que vous mesurez mais ça
a été évoqué avec les vacances à boucau
dantesque il est envisagé de mesurer
l'ampleur du du décrochage et les
possibilités de remédiation sur le sujet
mais qu'est ce taux qui a déjà été
abordé je pouvais pas faire plus gros
rouge merci céline brulin derrière son
écran
les neuf merci merci président madame
monsieur le ministre je crois qu'il ya
eu effectivement acceptation vous
m'entendez c'est bon je crois qu'il ya
eu acceptation du de l'interruption
scolaire du mois de mars et avril
parce que c'était assortie d'une
stratégie de vaccination et de tests qui
permettait ensuite de reprendre l'école
dans les meilleures conditions de
protection est ce que je regrette est ce
que beaucoup regrettent c'est que bien
que vous ayez dit monsieur le ministre
qui avait eu une préparation importante
pendant cette interruption
on s'aperçoit qu'aujourd'hui les choses
ne se sont pas du tout améliorée vous
avez évoqué les tests mais j'ai bien le
sentiment et je crois que les chiffres
en attestent qu'il y a aujourd'hui moins
d'enseignants qui sont testés que
c'était le cas avant cette interruption
à la pause quand même une vraie question
parce que l'idée de mettre à profit
cette interruption pour sécuriser tout
le monde
à la reprise était évidemment une idée
intéressante
je voudrais moi aussi intervenir sur la
question des remplacements
parce que c'est un vrai vrai sujet qui
ne tient pas seulement au quotidien il
ya des problèmes qui sont je dirais de
un peu de nature habituel mais je crois
qu'il ya un vrai effort a porté là
dessus
et donc ma question c'est est ce que
dans le plfr qui nous est annoncé pour
le mois de juillet il y aura des moyens
particuliers notamment pour assurer les
remplacements
là où il y en a besoin
même chose pour le soutien et les
soutiens particulier qu'on doit pouvoir
apporter un certain nombre d'enfants
parce qu'effectivement cette période
n'est pas vécue de la même manière par
les uns et par les autres
vous avez monsieur le ministre je vais
le dire peut-être un petit peu
brutalement mais un peu porter un peu
fait porter la responsabilité aux
collectivités d'un certain nombre de
dysfonctionnements je pense vous l'avez
vaucaire l'instant à tous les sujets
numériques et à ce que vous avez appelé
les tuyaux qui n'ont pas toujours
fonctionner convenablement pour assurer
les collants distant ciel mais je pense
aussi aux aérateurs au capteur de co2 et
à tout cela représente quand même des
coûts très importants pour les
collectivités qui ont d'ailleurs investi
pour beaucoup d'entre elles pour
améliorer augmenter le nombre de
sanitaires et c'est donc là aussi est ce
que dans le plfr on pourrait imaginer
qu'ils aient des moyens supplémentaires
attribuées aux collectivités pour
qu'elles puissent s'équiper et se mettre
au niveau surtout c'est sûr tous ces
aspects là et puis un dernier mot pour
pas être trop longue moi non plus je
vois qu'il ya des recherches sur les
examens qui ne donne pas entièrement
satisfaction mais qu'il ya des choses
qui bougent sauf il me semble dans un
domaine ce sont les lycées
professionnels et je crois qu'il ya un
sentiment d'abandon des des lycéens qui
sont dans les lycées professionnels et
qu'ils ont le sentiment qu'on ne se
préoccupe absolument pas de leurs
examens et je pense que c'est
c'est quelque chose sur lequel il faut
apporter des réponses parce que ce
sentiment d'abandon peut conduire on le
sait tous à des postures qui peuvent
nous emmener dans de drôles de travers
merci merci claude kern
oui merci monsieur le président alors
moi j'avais surtout intéressé aux sports
la reprise du sport c'est vrai qu'on se
réjouit tous deux de ce retour du sport
retour du public ça fait plus d'un an
qu'on était
sans cela ce sport sans compétition d'un
match amateur et c'est une belle lueur
d'espoir que
que nous avons aujourd'hui alors
moi je voudrais poser des questions
pratico pratique surtout puisque vous
avez nous ne nous avait détaillé le plan
de reprise avec le retour notamment des
spectateurs mais
si on salue si on peut saluer
aujourd'hui le passeport qui est
bienvenu qui est très attendu par par
les clubs
une question se pose en ce qui concerne
l'accompagnement dans ce que je dirais
c'est une cette phase de rodage phase de
reprise
est ce qu'il ya des moyens
supplémentaires qui sont prévus pour
accompagner les clubs qui sont en
difficulté un des points que vous n'avez
pas évoquer avec le retour des publics
vous savez que la plupart des clubs
amateurs
tiennent leurs finances grâce au lieu de
convivialité
je parlais des buvettes alors qu'en est
il à ceux à ce sujet est ce que une
réouverture est prévue la également avec
le retour dans les stades où l'ouverture
peut se faire à l'extérieur mais dans
les salles l'ouverture de ces buvettes
ne peut pas se faire à l'extérieur donc
ce serait bien de nous éclairer là
dessus enfin une question qui concerne
le sport de contact en salle vous nous
avez parlé du sport de contact en plein
air mais le sport recontacte en salle
est aussi très
attend également une reprise que soit la
lutte le judo et d'autres sports donc
que ce soit pour les mineurs et pour les
adultes
qu'en est il et pour terminer je sais
que c'est un peut-être un peu illusoire
d'en parler dès maintenant mais
avez-vous déjà réfléchi avec les
différentes fédérations
à la reprise on septembre thomas
d'haussy merci monsieur le président je
le ministre des madame la ministre
on commence à voir le bout du tunnel et
on doit s'en réjouir on espère que le
vaccin va nous permettre de ne pas
revivre une année scolaire aussi
compliqué on voit aussi donc le bull
cette année scolaire qui a épuisé
l'ensemble des équipes pédagogiques qui
on peut aussi leur rendre hommage
d'avoir tenu la baraque comme on dit et
puis la question qui va avec c'est
pourquoi tous les enseignants n'ont pas
été désignés comme voulu prioritaire
quel que soit leur âge afin d'être
vacciné assez rapidement qu'il
corollaire qui va avec je ne crois pas
que vous l'ayez évoqué mais quand est ce
qu'on va parce que vous l'avez évoqué je
crois dans une interview repasser au à
la fermeture de classes à partir de
trois cas qu vide
ce qu'il ya des critères objectifs pour
ce changement
et puis j'ai une question spécifique sur
les aes h sur le remplacement d un
message parce que j'ai été sollicité par
des parents cette semaine sur mon
territoire dans le rhône on leur a dit
qu'en mars il y avait 1000 aces h
absente et non remplacés sur le
département du rhône sur 4000 au total
dont 400 lyoko vie donc ce n'est pas
uniquement en raison de l'épidémie
s'il ya des répercussions assez graves
pour les pour les familles qui doivent
garder leurs enfants à la maison et donc
on envoie tient à un vrai décalage entre
les ambitions de la politique
d'éducation inclusive et puis une
réalité de parents qui sont souvent
démunis donc je vais savoir qu'est ce
qui est prévu
quels renforts et quelles améliorations
pour les conditions d un message à la
fois dans la rémunération de leurs
formations et puis j'ai une question
pour madame la ministre vous aviez dit
ici devant cette commission que le à la
réouverture les jauges des stades
seraient plutôt relative et là on en
voit qu'on est revenu à l'idée d'un d'un
seuil absolue à 5000
donc je laisse à voir si peut-être à la
réouverture de la saison ça sera sur des
jauges relative
et puis on a aussi entendu parler de
match test ce que c'est toujours
d'actualité
sabine van heghe si monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres
j interviens au nom du groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicains par une
question à monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale je rebondis sont
les propos de notre collègue jacques
grosperrin relatifs aux auto test
cette démarche est importante pour
lutter contre la propagation du convive
19 au sein des établissements et vous
l'avez dit les autotests sont mis à
disposition des lycéens volontaires
depuis le 10 mai raison d'une fois par
semaine les responsables syndicaux de
personnel et de direction éducation
nationale affirme pourtant que ces
objectifs sont irréalisables
car techniquement impossible en effet
une récente étude montre que pour un
établissement de 1000 élèves ses 58 eur
qui serait dédié à la réalisation des
autotests se trouve que le personnel
manque pour cela donc je souhaite vous
interroger monsieur le ministre sont les
modalités pratiques de mise en place d
auto thèse dans les lycées mais aussi
dans les collèges
je remercie reprendre toutes les
questions comme ça vous pourrez y
répondre globalement michel logique
merci monsieur le président monsieur
ministre pas même besoin de faire un
hors sujet c'était pas prévu mais je
peux faire' heures en profiter puisque
vous êtes là et je vous parlez moi de la
loi climat du ministre sur l'article 3
vous parler bien sûr des compétences des
conseils d'éducation à la santé à la
soigner tes aux préoccupations
d'environnement de développement durable
le savoir s'il existe aujourd'hui un
comité d'éducation à la santé à la
société dans les établissements
secondaires première question deuxième
un projet d'établissement devra être
élaborée tel que rédigé le texte prévoit
pour la mise en oeuvre de ce projet une
association des élèves des parents
d'élèves et des partenaires extérieurs
quel rôle donc pour les enseignantes
dans l'élaboration et la mise en oeuvre
de ce projet et puis juste une petite
réflexion je viens d'apprendre que le
pass sanitaire avait été rejeté à
l'assemblée
actional est-ce que ça remet en question
aujourd'hui la fin la mise en place des
nouvelles mesures dans le cadre de
retour à la vie normale et est ce que
tous vos espoirs reposent sur le sénat
laure darcos
merci monsieur le président mon ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation nationale je
voulais vous remercier au nom de tous
les élèves de terminale qui passent leur
bac en candidat libre via le cned
puisque vous avez fait paraître un
décret le 7 mai dernier pour annuler les
évaluations ponctuelles y compris
d'ailleurs celle d'éducation physique et
sportive au profit des notes obtenues
durant l'année et figurant dans le
livret scolaire
comme vous savez il ya eu beaucoup de
pétitions moi même avions avec mon
collègue de max brisson et beaucoup
d'autres de nos collègues nous avait
alertés avec un courrier et je vous
remercie beaucoup de ce dénouement mais
finalement pourquoi est ce que vous
n'avez pas fait avant parce que
finalement vous avait cristallisé
beaucoup de stress chez ses élèves
et en effet on en revient à plus
d'équité en tout cas je vous remercie
pour eux j'aurais m'engueuler merci
président monsieur le ministre madame la
ministre est heureux effectivement de
devoir les stades réouvrir enfin pour un
peu cette décision arrive et après la
fumée des cierges mais on va quand même
pouvoir voir le la dernière journée la
38e et palpitante journée de ligue 1 le
23 mai la finale de la coupe de france
le 29 mai pour ceux qui auront le
précieux sésame
ma question est relativement simple avez
vous à ce stade une vision sur la
reprise de la saison 2021 2022 qui
n'aura pas lieu en septembre
tout à l'heure notre collègue claude
carne parlait d'autres sports mais pour
le football dès le 25 juillet pour la
ligue 2 et
le sait tout pour la ligne 1 et le
national 2 ça c'est la première question
est la seconde et technique tout à
l'heure je crois que madame la ministre
la lie bauchet mais j'ai peut-être pas
forcément très bien compris dans les
dents les chiffres qui sont donnés deux
jauges 2000 ou de 5000 est-ce que les
staff les joueurs tout ce qui concourt à
l'organisation d'un match est compris
dans cette jauge où se sont en plus
véritablement que des spectateurs
merci c'est trivial merci monsieur le
président monsieur mini ce matin la
ministre
j'aurai deux deux questions tout d'abord
la première d'abord pour partager le
satisfecit qui est qui et très
consensuel sur l'ouverture des écoles et
la posture et là que vous avez tenus
monsieur le ministre durant toute cette
période de crise avec les difficultés
que ça pouvait supposer
je voulais vous en remercier rappelé à
cette occasion que non seulement les
collectivités ont fait preuve de
beaucoup de souplesse et d'adaptabilité
dans leur très grande majorité ça a été
aussi le cas des enseignants et des
directeurs d'école qui ont fait preuve
là aussi dans cette crise de de beaucoup
de de don de soi
c'est vrai pour leur immense majorité et
leur écrasante majorité mais on a quand
même quelques situations d'enseignants
qui n'ont pas forcément une attitude
très contributive 10 ans ou qui ont soit
refusé d'appliquer un certain nombre de
protocoles soient ont pu prendre
prétexte du contexte sanitaire pour des
absences pas forcément justifiées ou qui
lorsque l'école était en distance yale
ont pas forcément jouer le jeu de
l'accompagnement qui était nécessaire
ma question est assez ça monsieur mais
nice est ce que vous avez fait ce qu'il
y a eu des sanctions contre ces
enseignants ou est-ce qu'elles sont
prévues
quand certains n'ont pas joué le jeu et
qu'ils jettent du coup le discrédit sur
l'ensemble de la profession alors que
d'autres le l'ont fait avec beaucoup de
coeur et d'ardeur ma deuxième question
elle est liée au contexte sanitaire mais
elle se projette un peu sur l'année
prochaine
c'est la situation des classes de
découvertes et des classes de neige qui
malheureusement ont pas pu avoir lieu
cette année et qui pose d'immenses
difficultés pour pour notamment le ces
centres de vacances ou les laisser les
stations qui peuvent les accueillir
je sais que vous réfléchissez à cette
question est ce que monsieur le ministre
vous pouvez déjà nous dire comment vous
envisagez
cela l'année prochaine est ce que le
ministère prévoit une politique
incitative auprès des enseignants pour
soi assouplir peut-être les procédures
administratives soient peut-être
accompagné financièrement ou accompagné
en encourageant ses classes de
découvertes et ses classes de neige pour
qu'elle se déroule dans les meilleures
conditions possible l'année prochaine
puisque vous le savez nécessite un petit
peu aussi d'anticipations donc est-ce
que vous pouvez nous en dire un petit
peu plus sur la le souhait du ministère
pour encourager ses classes de neige ce
sera déterminant pour leur survie
l'année prochaine merci beaucoup michel
savin madame la ministre monsieur
ministre bien sûr on est tous très
heureux du retour des activités
sportives notamment pour les amateurs
qui depuis des mois était en souffrance
on c'est une bonne idée très bonne
nouvelle je vais pas reprendre ce qu'on
dit tous mes collègues je veux revenir
sur deux ou trois points alors pour le
prochain raymond hugo n'est peut-être
que je vais refroidir un peu ça qu'on
adore c'est que je mets ma mise pour tv
nous confirmer mais je crois pas que
pour la finale finale de la coupe de
france ira possibilité d'avoir du public
j'ai cru comprendre que la finale je
pourrai toujours à huis clos et c'était
une des questions c'était le couvre-feu
qui démarre à 21h comment articuler
concrètement ces deux règles il sera en
opposition dans de nombreux cas et c'est
le cas déjà avec la finale de la coupe
de france qui se jouera donc à huit clos
la fédération française n'ayant pas
obtenu des dérogations de coups au feu
donc que j'aurai mon site à un billet
ben ali des idées bien
pour plus sérieusement sur sur la
réouverture des piscines donc j'ai bien
compris que on a bien entendu que pour
le scolaire c'était possible est-ce
qu'il est prévu madame la ministre un
protocole de monsieur le ministre qu'un
protocole pour cet été notamment pour
les collectivités parce qu'elles sont en
train de recruter les maîtres nageurs et
c'est vrai que l'année passée on avait
des protocoles en terme de deux nombres
de deux publics à accueillir avec des
protocoles important aussi en termes de
sanitaires donc est-ce quelque chose qui
est prévu à quel moment les
collectivités pour en tête
informer sur ce protocole de revêtir les
piscines je veux revenir aussi sur le
problème des choses qui a évoqué notre
collègue et c'est vrai que le président
de la république avait lui même parlé
d'un retour du public en fonction de la
capacité d'accueil des enceintes et
aujourd'hui on voit qu'on est plutôt sur
une jauge et savait qu'on était un petit
peu surprenant que lorsqu'on est un
stade de 10000 ou de 60000 on n'est pas
dans les mêmes disponibilités
d'exposition et c'était un pourcentage
de nous aurait paru beaucoup plus
intéressant et à traiter avec les
fédérations et des participants là aussi
une précision mesdames les ministres sur
les organisations d'événements les
organisateurs d'événements sportifs de
plein air qui ont annulé quasiment
toutes leurs manifestations l'année
passée des règles présentées pour le
déconfinement pose question ainsi au 9
juin
ce qu on a pu lire c'est que pour les
courses à pied notamment le pressent
limité à 500 participants et lorsqu'on
sait on voit que dans le même temps pour
accueillir 5000 personnes dans des
salles intérieures
donc est-ce que vous pouvez nous
préciser expliquer ces décisions qui
sont un petit peu en contradiction
enfin monsieur le ministre sur la
réouverture des accueils collectifs de
mineurs qui a été annoncé pour le 20
juin c'était une très bonne nouvelle
pour les centres de loisirs et les
colonies de vacances mais à quel moment
aura t'on les règles applicables et que
les protocoles là aussi parce que les
collectivités mais aussi les
associations sont en train de programme
mais leur sortie l'organisation le
nombre de personnes à recruter et donc
les inscriptions se déroulent en ce
moment et donc il était important
d'avoir une certaine visibilité sur
cette organisation voilà monsieur le
président c'était fade pieds noirs ainsi
mis en valeur
c'est le président rapidement madame la
ministre ce le ministre dans le concert
sinon de louanges au moins largement
consensuel que mes collègues ont pu
exprimer
précédemment je pourrais pas vous
décevoir en vous laissant repartir sur
une petite note quand même deux sinon
deux critiques au moins de scepticisme
sur une des des mesures que vous avez
prises
s'agissant des tests dans les écoles et
de la mesure de fermeture dès lors qu'un
test est positif les y compris les
autotests j'ai aujourd'hui lui un retour
d'un test d'infos test positif qui a
entraîné la fermeture d'une classe
peut-être je rejoins mon collègue qui
disait la même chose tout à l'heure
peut-être que nous pourrions aller sur
une fermeture à partir de trois ou
quatre cas positifs avérée parce que là
on voit bien qu'il ya des flux des
défilés même des fluctuations de
d'effectifs à l'intérieur d'une âme
écoles qui peuvent poser problème sur
sur les examens notamment le
baccalauréat je rejoins les propos de
max brisson sur les grèves évidemment il
vous sera il vous sera difficile de
faire même pas mieux que l'an dernier
aussi bien que l'an dernier avec une
progression de plus de 7 points sur la
le taux de réussite au baccalauréat on
voit bien que dans l'imaginaire un petit
peu des lycéens et les néo bachelier il
ya une espèce de course à l'échalote
escalade
il ya un plafond de verre qui est quand
même le faon % de réussite dans ce
domaine
et puis troisième point pour plus
particulièrement sur le sport on a
entendu tout à l'heure les l'ouverture
des de certaines compétitions pouvait
être soumise à
au pass sanitaires là aussi ça a été
évoqué tout à l'heure 108 à 103 c'est le
résultat du vote à l'assemblée nationale
en défaveur du pass sanitaire est ce que
ça remet en question cette stratégie
pour différentes d'ouverture un papa
seulement les compétitions sportives
évidemment je suis comme michel laugier
jeu je connais la sagesse du sénat mais
néanmoins c'est quand même un pavé dans
la mare dans la stratégie globale de la
lutte contre le coc vidal merci et je
rajouterais juste une question je crois
que les épreuves orales du bac français
ont été prolongé d'une semaine passant
de une à deux semaines pour quelques
réactions chez les enseignants quelle a
été la motivation du rangement sur deux
semaines voilà ce mini semaine à la
ministre l'ensemble des questions qui
témoigne de l'intérêt de la commission
mais vous le savez à 7 quai à cette
reprise des activités auxquelles nous
sommes évidemment comme vous attachez
c'est pas qu'ils commencent à répondre
de ses ministres merci monsieur le
président et merci à tous les sénateurs
et s'attriste composé dé des questions
le sur les questions posées par sur le
sénateur brisson
donc il ya d'abord la question de la
vaccination
donc il ya ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure sur ce qui s'est passé en
matière de centres dédiés qui est quand
même un qui est quand même intéressant
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai par le
succès relatif c'est pas rien d'avoir
une vingtaine de milliers de personnes
qui sont fait vacciner de l'os de la
sorte il ya aussi des professeurs qui
sont qui ont été vaccinées par
différents biais leur médecin leur
pharmacien un peu comme en population
générale
il est à préciser un point qui comme
important c'est que bien sûr jeu comme
vous le savez je suis l'avocat et si
possible acteurs d'une vaccination
prioritaire des professeurs une donnée à
avoir à l'esprit c'est que les
professeurs sont fort heureusement une
catégorie professionnelle moins
contaminés que la moyenne de la
population ce qui tient d'ailleurs à
respect des gestes-barrières justement
une forme de 2,2 bon respect de
l'ensemble des règles qui ont été
établies montrent au passage d'ailleurs
que comme je les ai souvent dit le
milieu scolaire n'est pas un milieu de
contamination spécifiques
ça ne sait donc ce qui permet d'être
d'envisager avec sérénité ce qui ce qui
suit néanmoins le notre objectif reste
encore en mai juin d'avoir la
vaccination de tous les tous les
professeurs au moins pour une première
injection pour les plus de 50 ans bien
sûr comme toute la population générale
mais très rapidement et nous avons un
conseil de défense demain vous et pour
quel peut-être ces questions avanceront
d'un cran sur le remplacement des
professeurs
alors je tiens à dire que nous avons mis
des moyens supplémentaires importants
sur la question du remplacement ou de
remplacement on a
fait recruter 2200 remplaçant pour le
premier degré en particulier et puis
nous avons aujourd'hui même
enfin en ce moment même c'est à dire
dans ce troisième trimestre scolaire
dans lequel nous sommes instruction aux
recteurs de recruter la question était
posée par un brillant ensuite sur ce que
nous faisons en pf et l'air nous serons
peut-être même à régulariser certains
recrutement de contractuels que nous
faisons actuellement
donc le sujet au moment où je vous parle
ce n'est pas tant que nous n'aurions pas
les moyens budgétaires du remplacement
mais plutôt parfois des difficultés rh
si je puis dire de remplacement mais les
moyens nous les avons mis parce que en
effet on a rencontré les limites de
notre potentiel de remplacement qui est
souvent autour de 8 10% et qui est
parfois dépassée par les circonstances
on a néanmoins un taux de remplacement
qui qui reste correct dans beaucoup de
paca est toujours supérieur à 90% mais
c'est évidemment toujours très pénible
quand compte se contient remplacement
qui n'est pas effectuée vous m'avez
demandé des nouvelles du grenelle en
quelque sorte
donc comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure il n'est pas du tout remis en
cause ça veut pas dire ça débouche sur
une loi de programmation mais ça veut
dire que la perspective dans laquelle
nous sommes c'est une amélioration des
rémunérations en 2021 et en 2022
dans une perspective qui trace une
trajectoire d'augmentation pour les
années suivantes
sutil d'ailleurs laisse pleine manoeuvre
à ceux qui gouverneront à partir de
demain 2022 bien sûr nous avons des
propositions en la matière et le
grenelle des bouches 1 sur une vision du
rattrapage nécessaire des salaires des
professeurs et ce ne sont pas que des
paroles verbales puisque ça s'enclenche
dès maintenant en espèces sonnantes et
trébuchantes mais aussi de
transformation et je leur dis de la
gestion des ressources humaines du ce
ministère
évidemment je ne sais pas le moment là
de d'exposer tout cela mais ce sera la
conséquence très concrète de ce qui des
travaux qui ont été accomplis maintenant
depuis plusieurs mois dans le calme dans
le cadre du grenelle de l'éducation
depuis le mois de novembre avec très
nombreux participants et tout ceci est
donc désormais à maturité votre objectif
en étant l'une des organisations les
plus importantes au monde je rappelle
que c'est plus de un million cent mille
salariés dans le dernier pointage que
faisait nous étions peut-être la
troisième organisation au monde en
termes de nombre de salariés
l'objectif est de montrer que nous
pouvons avoir une gestion des ressources
humaines modernes personnalisé et non
pas anonymes et et éventuellement
frustrante quand c'est trop anonyme ce
qui a parfois été le cas en tout cas
c'est un reproche que l'on entend
souvent là l'objectif est de tenir
compte de vraiment de de la carrière de
chacun des des aspirations de chacun
avoir beaucoup plus de fluidité est
beaucoup plus d' écoute aussi des
personnels sujet sur lequel je
reviendrai évidemment devant vous dans
dans les prochaines semaines
vous avez posé une question qui est
vraiment importante parce qu'elle est
toutes vos questions sont importantes
d'assurer la sueur sur l'obligation
scolaire en vous demandant si elle
n'avait pas reculé
à l'occasion de cette crise et vous
demander s'ils ne fallait pas peut-être
une campagne de communication
je vous ferai une réponse à la fois
responsable et optimiste c'est je pense
que non seulement elle n'a pas reculé
mais là elle s'est améliorée dans l'est
dans les têtes
alors je veux bien sûr je passe sur les
aspects juridiques et administratifs
l'obligation scolaire de l'instruction
obligatoire désormais à trois ans et qui
est même maintenant une forme de
scolarisation obligatoire à 3 ans avec
des exceptions
7 donc il y avait bien dans ce cadre
renforcé et que vous connaissez
désormais très bien mais il ya aussi la
dimension qu'on peut qualifier de
psychologique est ce que je prétends et
big évidemment peut être fortement
débattue mais c'est que à l'occasion de
la crise sanitaire la france a en
quelque sorte renouer son alliance avec
son école c'est à dire que l'ensemble de
la population a pris conscience de
l'importance décisive de l'école je
pensais à la fois un sujet mondial est
un sujet français c'est à dire il y
avait des discours avant la crise
deux épidémies
2 sur la fin mais colle sur le
remplacement du du professeur par la
machine sûr il ya même des utopies
post-68 avec ivan illich sur la fin de
l'école donc 7
cette approche là c'est utopique elle
soit de différents bords politiques ou
philosophiques ses utopies avec beaucoup
de guillemets sont à mon avis balayé
totalement parce que nous on dit c'est à
tout le monde se rend compte de
l'importance d'avoir un professeur
physiquement présent d'avoir un
professeur qui n ont pas soumis à la
machine mais maître de la machine
d'avoir donc une véritable affectio
societatis pour l'école je pense que le
monde entier est en train de réaliser ça
et que la france le réalise tout
particulièrement
d'abord parce qu'elle a c'est son
histoire singulière avec l'école école
colonne vertébrale de la république et
que on le voit aussi dans
par exemple les enquêtes d'opinion sur
le désir de retour à l'école qu'ils sont
plus forts en france que ailleurs on l'a
beaucoup vu dans une sorte de vote avec
les pieds si vous me permettez
l'expression de delà du mois de
septembre c'est à dire et ça répond
aussi d'ailleurs un peu à votre question
suivante qui est sur l'ampleur du
décrochage ou on a vu tout le monde
revenir à l'école au mois de septembre
et où on a eu donc moins de décrocher en
2020 qu'en 2019 une espèce de plébiscite
pour l'école en quête d'un plébiscite de
chaque jour pour l'école comme peut-être
aurait dit ronan est donc cette
évidemment c'est la vision optimiste on
peut aussi dire que cette crise a créé
de la distance etc
mais il ya un autre élément d'optimisme
qui est la relation parents école qui
est aussi un sujet
fondamentale et difficile qui à certains
égards et à beaucoup d'égards même s'est
renforcé pendant la crise parce que mes
parents ont été obligés de s'en mêler à
un moment donné en désirant d'ailleurs
s'en mêler - ultérieurement
mais en tout cas cela crée parfois du
lien parents école donc que qu'il faut
mesurer
[Musique]